oh
le quartier du bas de la rivière à saint
denis était autrefois un lieu à vocation
industrielle et agricole
il a activement participé au
développement du chef lieu de la réunion
très actif ce quartier a été fortement
peuplées et très urbanisées mais les
fermetures successives des usines ont
considérablement réduit la fréquentation
du quartier presque laissé à l'abandon
le conseil général a souhaité redonner
vie au bas de la rivière et en faire un
éco quartier pilote expérience qui
pourrait ensuite être développée sur
d'autres communes après des aménagements
urbains et la renaissance du collège
rabelais il s'agit maintenant de
relancer une vie sociale dans ce lieu
chargé d'histoire le conseil général a
donc cherché des solutions pour
permettre aux différentes populations de
se retrouver d'échanger de partager
c'est de cette conviction que sont nées
les marchés pays qui ont lieu tous les
deuxièmes mercredis du mois à l'espace
redley l'objectif est d'apporter du
soutien aux agriculteurs réunionnais
dont certains exerçant à saint denis en
leur offrant plus de points de vente et
permettre aux habitants du quartier de
redécouvrir les produits péi de qualité
patrick et d'agriculteurs depuis 25 ans
il connaît bien les difficultés que
rencontre le monde agricole en général
et trouve que le marché pays est une
belle idée qui lui apporte un soutien
financier mais aussi social va passer
devant les marches forêt baselworld et
fois c'est pas pareil être concurrents
ont pour écouler les produits très très
difficile je trouve c'est très
intéressant au niveau contact avec les
gens au niveau de l'avant même au niveau
mais au niveau financièrement pour le
pour mon revenu
c'est un plus j'ai présenté le kappa tau
légumes est très très anciens ont dit
qu'ils découvrent des choses et aussi on
découvre notre clientèle a fait
connaissance que tu aimes tu peux avoir
la donne et nous aider au choix
j'ai dit aux responsables qui intrigue
faut pas arrêter faut pas arrêter faut
continuer parce qu'il rapporte quand
même quelque chose avait culte et aux
artisans ceux qui viennent ici
as été très très bon comme patrick
beaucoup d'agriculteurs ont besoin de
soutien
l'aspect financier n'est pas la seule
raison d'aider le monde agricole
ce sont des métiers très difficile et la
reconnaissance n'est pas forcément au
rendez-vous grâce au marché pays
les agriculteurs présents sur les stands
peuvent partager l'amour de leur métier
avec les clients ils peuvent parler avec
passion de leurs produits au grand
bonheur des acheteurs
c'est une équation parfaite car le
client et trouve non seulement des
produits frais mais à meilleur prix
car c'est une vente directe entre
l'agriculteur et le consommateur
autrefois surnommé le grenier de saint
denis le quartier du bas de la rivière
est en train de renouer avec le
mieux-vivre écoquartier en cours
il revit grâce à des animations
économique et social le marché pays est
un formidable moyen de relier les gens
entre eux les populations se retrouvent
échanges et partages elle redécouvre des
produits qui ont fait la réunion
tout cela en aidant les agriculteurs et
en proposant des produits à meilleur
prix au consommateur le marché pays est
un exemple à suivre car il prouve que la
solidarité apporter des solutions à tous
les acteurs d'un même dispositif
le marché pays c'est tous les deuxièmes
mercredis du mois à l'espace raid l'est
au bas de la rivière